hey theo uh it's kennedy helen from
virginia thank you for calling man from
virginia over there and virginia's
second place in the civil war
let's hear it you know i was in san
francisco i'm out there this homeless
guy turns around
throws a [ __ ] bird right at me dead
bird pigeon straight shot right at me
dude
and i was with this chick i think she's
a lesbian and uh she
[ __ ] caught that [ __ ] dude so that's
the kind of [ __ ] that's going on along
the coast
hey there this is steve from new jersey
um thank you for calling
steve uh new jersey beautiful place man
probably one of the top
50 places in america i think homework
just to be down there on the gulf coast
and you can't even get any cocaine down
there because it's wet everything's wet
down there you find a oyster in the damn
cocaine
you'll do half a line and [ __ ] next
thing you know you got a pearl
hey theo this is dakota from oklahoma
what's up dakota and that's a tornado
country
you know so you leave a [ __ ] rubik's
cube in the yard and the wind will
[ __ ] do it
in toronto that kind of plays great
posture you see somebody you barely see
them because they're such a straight
perpendic you know uh straight uh
vertical this is julian powers
colin from niagara falls canada and
that's a clean water thoroughfare up
there
niagara man i want to thank you too
because we drink a lot of that and we've
been sipping off of y'all for a while
sucking off that clean titty while we
down here flinting gang [ __ ] homer
hey theo this is emily from jacksonville
florida
what's up emily duval
and jacksonville is a good place to get
electrocuted by a down stoplight
in portland they say they got a lot of
beautiful strippers up there and a lot
of rain
so if you like that whap if you like a
damp girl that's really pale skin but
tatted up
one of them antifa bad [ __ ] that's
your territory
hey what's up theo it's uh nate from
indiana dirty nate
from indiana and i saw a tow truck hit
an owl one time in indiana and that's
true
montreal is diverse man i mean if you're
racist you can
barely figure out who to hate very
tricky it's a tough place i think if
you're a racist to really
get specific to lock your targets you
know to top gun on somebody
san francisco smells like you got people
do doing in their shorts oh yeah and doo
doo really is just hard thick brown piss
that's more like [ __ ]
more and maui has special characters
you'll see somebody
they're growing uh they'll have like
dreadlocks and then half of their hair
will have uh
crops built into the side of it they'll
be growing wheat
up half their scalp and they got birds
over there too you'll see a bird you've
never even seen
nobody's seen him you'll crack open a
coconut and inside there'll be a
homeless dude
in there smoking dmt one time i was
jogging in the midwest
and that's the real thick belt and
somebody stopped some guy's like
he pulled over he's like what are you
running from man you're scared of
something
like nah man i'm this is fitness buddy
i'm doing i'm doing fitness i'm an adult
man
in this place if you haven't been to
washington dc
every building looks like a library i'm
at a subway sandwich
and next thing you know they putting
periodicals on my um
six inch suite what up theo this is neil
from orlando what up neal from orlando
and i'll say this about your area neil
that's a bright area
that is just damn bright afghanistan you
better have on a hat
a cowboy hat you better have some dude
park right behind you with a camper
and throw that awning out because
grandma's skinning catfish bruh
and we need that cover what's up maurice
from maine
uh you know i freaking met a girl up
there i remember a bat was flying at us
bruh
and we was up there in an abandoned
house and i hit that [ __ ] with a uh
tennis racket man that andre agassi bro
hit that [ __ ] that little [ __ ] air
bastard bruh
that little [ __ ] cough smuggler came
at us brian i i
clipped that [ __ ] out the sky uh onward
sir
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been